au sommaire un sentier en balcon à
mafate de lille est des lataniers jusqu
à roche plate la curiosité de la semaine
lille est des lataniers
pour cette randonnée en plein coeur du
cirque de mafate notre point de
rendez-vous et lille est des lataniers
accessible depuis le maïdo la
canalisation des orangers ou encore le
pont de la rivière des galets
pour cette randonnée de difficulté
moyenne longue de 6 km prévoir de bonnes
chaussures de quoi vous protéger du
soleil et une réserve d'eau
pour votre santé parcourez nos sentiers
depuis il est des lataniers le sentier
le plus fréquemment empruntée pour
rejoindre roches plates et celui qui
passe par la brèche et lille est des
orangers il en existe pourtant un autre
moins connus mais qui mérite le détour
et qui commencent tout juste à la sortie
de l'île est
taillé dans les roches friable sous la
crête des orangers la première partie de
ce sentier est assez exposée et ne doit
surtout pas être empruntée par temps de
pluie
à flanc de falaise vertigineuse
ils offrent de superbes points de vue
sur la rivière des galets sur cayenne ou
sur la roche ancrée tout en conférant un
parfum d'aventuré mais s'il impressionne
de loin ce sentier finalement très
praticable grâce aux marche très bien
taillée
après 500 m de traversée aérienne le
sentier retrouve une pente plus douce
couverte de végétation sèche
caractéristiques de cette partie basse
de mafate et dans laquelle on trouve
parfois de beaux arbres comme ceux
jamblon en fruits
le sentier continue plein sud en
parallèle de la rivière des galets et
conduit jusqu en dessous de lille est à
cordes un ancien ministre il est que
vous ne verrez pas puisqu'il n'en reste
rien aujourd'hui et dont le nom
viendrait de la corde que ses habitants
devaient utiliser pour pouvoir s'y
hisser
le sentier rejoint maintenant le sentier
d'acer le plus connu des mafate et sous
le nom de sentiers facteurs qui relie
grand-place à roche plate par la roche
ancrée il est d'autant plus utilisés
aujourd'hui que les boulistes survenu au
cape noire rend inaccessibles itinéraire
dans le lit de la rivière des galets à
l'aplomb du broncha pour rejoindre la
partie haute du cirque
qu'on ne s'y trompe pas cette montée
courte jusqu à roche plate fait de
marche pourtant bien aménagé plutôt
difficile d'autant qu'il ya peu de
l'ombre pour s'abriter du soleil son
itinéraire a également été rallongée
filantes auparavant tout droit vers auch
plate église le sentier passe désormais
juste sous le broncha au niveau du
cimetière de l'yvette
d'accord
à l'intersection du gr 2 le sentier
permet de bifurquer vers l'ouest pour
traverser une grande partie de l'île est
pas besoin
comme souvent dans le cirque les
hélicoptères effectuent leur ballet
autour des îles est ce jour-là un
tournage d'émissions télé justifier la
présence soutenue de deux d'entre eux
encore quelques centaines de mètres et
nous rejoignons l'école de roches plates
qui matérialise la fin de notre
randonnée
ce que j'aime sur ce sentier surtout pas
qu'on devine bien la difficulté qu'il ya
tout un commencement il puisse aldrin
bien sûr le rend pas et toutes les
falaises qui est autour et puis c'est
une autre itinéraire
pourra pas passer par un athlète c'est
un sentier emprunté parce que par la
difficulté déjà et les gens connaissent
peu aussi cette partie là parce que
souvent on passe à la roche ancrée pour
aller directement vers cayenne ou
grand-place mon pass très rarement pour
aller directement vers l'élite de
l'année ce que j'aime pas sur ce sentier
bien c'est justement les marges qui sont
trop hautes comme moi qui ai une petite
jambes c'est assez difficile c'est la
seule chose que j'aime pas
situé à 620 mètres d'altitude face à
cayenne lille est des lataniers est
positionné sur une étroite bande de
terre au bout de la crête des orangers
lilas des lataniers est l'un des plus
petits il est de mafate avec seulement
une douzaine de cases répartis le long
d'un sentier principal pour une
vingtaine d'habitants
située dans une zone à risques naturels
élevée au dessus du lit de la rivière
des galets lille est est désormais
classé totalement inconstructible
toutefois grâce au captage de la source
grand mère il est suffisamment fournis
en haut pour permettre d'y mener une
activité agricole
quant au nom de lille est il viendrait
de la présence à l'époque de latanier
rouge un petit palmiers endémiques de la
réunion
où